Ein kleines Felsennest mit imposanter
Burganlage – das ist Gruyères,
umgeben von den Ausläufern
der Schweizer Alpen.
Der Name Gruyères verweist
auf das Wappentier der Gemeinde,
den Kranich, französisch „la grue“.
Etwa 2.000 Menschen leben hier, aber
jährlich kommen rund eine Million Touristen.
Und den berühmten Käse
kennt natürlich jeder.
Kenne ich gut, schmeckt toll,
den gibt’s auch in Brasilien.
Ich mag vor allem den alten Gruyère.
Wenn wir Zeit haben, probieren wir den.
Rund um den Ort grasen
Kühe der Holsteiner Rasse.
51 Alpkäsereien im Kanton stellen den
Käse auf ganz traditionelle Weise her.
Auf 1.600 Metern Höhe hat die
Familie Piller ihre Hütte.
52 Kühe gehören zur Käserei.
Béat Piller arbeitet rund um
die Uhr an der Käseherstellung.
In einem großen Kupferkessel
beginnt die erste Phase.
Wenn die Milchmasse dickflüssig ist,
rührt er sie immer wieder mit
zwei Holzschaufeln durch.
Der Anfang ist am
allerwichtigsten bei der Herstellung.
Mit diesen Schaufeln sorgen wir dafür,
dass sich die Masse in Körner scheidet.
Jetzt steht die Geburtsstunde
des Käses bevor.
Per Hand lässt sich am besten prüfen,
welche Konsistenz die Körner haben.
Für den Gruyère wird nur
Rohmilch verwendet.
Das ist eine gute Qualität.
Ich kontrolliere das mit der Hand.
Wir haben hier keine technischen
Apparate, um etwas zu prüfen.
Wir verlassen uns ganz
auf unsere Sinne.
Hier kann man schon fühlen,
wie weich er ist.
Schauen Sie, wie sich die
Körner herauslösen.
Mehr Technik und viele Bottiche
gibt es in einer Schaukäserei
ganz in der Nähe von Gruyères.
Anders als in den Alpkäsereien
haben hier Besucher Zutritt
und beobachten die Herstellung von oben.
Die Käselaibe reifen bei 13 Grad Celsius.
Jeder Laib erhält einen Stempel,
der die Herkunft nachweist.
Auf dem Käse ist die Nummer der
Käserei angegeben, diese Nummer hier.
Außerdem findet man die Nummer auch
auf der Verpackung des Gruyère.
Wer also beispielsweise den Gruyère
in Deutschland kauft, kann im Internet
die Nummer eingeben und herausfinden,
aus welcher Käserei dieser Käse,
den man isst, eigentlich stammt.
Nur die Milch von Kühen, die auf den
Wiesen von Gruyères weiden,
wird zu dem berühmten Käse verarbeitet.
Er wurde mehrfach als bester
Hartkäse der Welt ausgezeichnet.